everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie today I am wearing my high school
football jerseys
we had a special day at work where you
could wear a jeans and your favorite
team's Jersey if you donated some money
to a charity so I decided why not wear
my Jersey because pretty much never ever
have an appropriate occasion to wear it
and when I say football I mean American
football so for those of you from other
countries
I know football means would I call suck
let's see oh I need to get my spot if I
go in yesterday's throwback Thursday
playlist was all 90s music which was
really fun because I grew up in the 90s
so maybe I'll just play that there we go
let's listen to 90's music today in the
background
all right so today we're gonna work on
some of the same stuff we were working
on yesterday and we may switch it up and
do some stuff on the homepage or you
know maybe like in the app bar at the
top we'll see how it goes
I did get some some more data
transferred over so I don't plan on
making any more routes but if we could
use that Universal component to check on
some of that data then that'll be cool
when then we can look at the styles for
that and to say hi to everyone Nikki's
here how's it going
also Victor San bassist I like your
Jersey thank you somebody says hey you
play football in high school when we
play cricket cool I've actually never
played cricket before I've only seen it
like in movies really it looks fun
though
John Hanson says it's a that's cool it's
a good way to donate to charity yeah
yeah it's cool we do that occasionally I
think we have a day like that in
Christmas where you bring in presence
and then they they give it to local
children who these families don't have
enough money to buy presents for
Christmas so we get like you can wear a
Christmas sweater day let's see somebody
says what charity I don't remember what
it's called I gotta check the email I
still haven't written my check yet for
it so I need to look up the name anyway
let's see oh it's gonna go to the
scholarship fund so students who do not
have enough money today to attend school
here will get financial help so that's
cool all right so let's let's get
started I want to make sure I start my
my timer oh and we can't go
more than an hour and a half I have a
meeting with my boss he wants a timeline
for when everything's going to be done
not only for this site but for some
future projects and future additions to
this site which I'll have to remember to
tell you about today I said I was going
to tell you yesterday and then I forgot
so we can talk about that maybe later
hopefully I won't forget again let's say
I feel like I'm forgetting something but
maybe maybe I'm not maybe I just didn't
have a lot of stuff to say oh I know
what it is I want to say thank you to
Nikki for the pull request so as you all
probably noticed if you've been watching
for the last few days I keep having to
restart the server manually every time
we make a change in the server j/s file
so now we're as Harshit suggested
yesterday we're using node Mon to watch
for changes on a server j/s file and
automatically restart the server so
it'll save a little bit of time it'll
definitely save me some annoyance and
anyways it's really cool so if you have
the repo and you do a pool make sure you
run yarn because we have some new NPM
packages in there so it won't work
otherwise but now it is kind of cool we
don't need to manually restart all right
Harsha thank you for reminding me to
switch my screen there we are
and so I may ask one question you like
your boss I I do really like my boss yep
I actually I knew my boss before I got
the job here we're actually both
officers in this non-pro I co-founded a
non-profit here
where I'm from and so he's our treasurer
for that nonprofit organization so we
kind of knew each other beforehand and
now yeah I really like my boss so he's a
good boss
I like everybody my department is great
it's really nice nice place all right
Wow a lot going on there don't really
need to see that there right now let's
start your timer and get to work
also let's go to the homepage No
okay it is a link for a second I didn't
think it was a link nothing was
happening but so I just wanted to go
here and show you all this is my boss
Tom crow is my boss and that's his
picture that's a pretty old picture but
he still pretty much looks exactly the
same
all right
so we're we had I honestly do not
remember at all where we left off I
think remind me if I'm wrong here
correct me if I'm wrong here
the last thing that we worked on were
that was the size for H tags I think
that's what we had done we had changed
font sizes we changed some font weights
and we were I we did art I I'm almost
positive this was what we did yesterday
and we kind of ended by testing that out
and looking at the various fonts Jeff
Miller thank you for reminding me about
the end rot link let's get that started
there we are and grok link is now in the
live chat all right well since I'm on
the home page right now let's just check
the home page and see what's going on if
there's anything that we really need to
change you know style wise let's see and
in case you you didn't watch the stream
and we talked about this I want to do
everything from a mobile point of view
first and the we're gonna obviously pay
attention to desktop view but I think
this is the better way to go given our
audience of you know mostly American
teenagers as we can check let's check
this out all right so here's something
that I've been meaning to change for a
while let's change the let's change the
width first I'm going to make this side
navigation drawer a little bit more
narrow and I want to see how that looks
and then potentially make change the
width of this you see right now we have
more space on this side than we do on
this side so I don't want to change it
yet I'm gonna wait and see what happens
when we make this a little more narrow
all right so we can just test it out in
in dev tools here at first let's see let
me get that container
so with
let's figure out where the width is I
must be in a larger component maybe
who a smaller one that's interesting
hmm I'm gonna check this component
because I'm not sure where that's coming
in from let me make this font a bit
bigger for everyone we can shrink this
and let's check out our drawer component
so I'm guessing it's some prop or
something with is the list with 300
interesting maybe it's just getting the
width from the list or the list classes
the list so this div is what's 300 okay
just
it's this diff okay now we can shrink it
here oh okay I like that
I like I like I don't like that it's a
weird number but all right let's let's
check it out
I want to make sure it looks like
everything will fit and it does look
like everything will fit I like how all
this looks the spacing is good I was
hoping if that would happen that when we
shrunk the drawer a bit that this would
work itself out to save us a bit of time
actually I really like that and I plan
on decreasing the the indent decreasing
the white space here so we'll actually
have even more space for our menu items
when we do that that that'll actually
probably the next thing we work on so I
want to keep the width here so let's go
back to our component and up here this
is gonna look a little bit different
than your normal CSS right this is we're
in a react component and then react
components generally you'll you'll find
a lot of different ways to do styles but
one of the ways is to actually put it
right in the component like this and so
it's a it's a constant and it is a
JavaScript object but we still use all
the same names and properties as we do
in CSS we just camelcase them or you
know we put them it we make them strings
so a little bit different but once you
get used to you know putting thing
making things strings camel casing and
obviously using the you know correct
formatting for an object it's basically
the same as a normal CSS and we want to
apply it down here well at least for the
way we have this set up we just use
class name equals and then we put
brackets to denote we're using some
JavaScript and then we just do that
classes dot list
remember it's an object so we're putting
in near the classes object and then the
list property right because if you see
these this is like key values right we
have lists but then in the value is
another object what that contains a key
value pair of with 300 right so we can
use dot notation to grab that that value
anyway so a little refresher or
introduction depending on where you're
at with your you know react training so
anyway let's change this value so I
believe we added at 265 and I'm not you
know I'm not set on 265 but I'd like to
try it out for a little bit and see how
I like it
and I do want to do a refresh just to
make sure that that worked yep and that
works
okay now let's check out our items here
what's that's interesting these are
actually H threes
very interesting and these are I don't
believe that we made these age threes we
can double check when we go back to the
component but I think this was what they
become in material UI it's really
interesting all right so why is it
that's this one right padding left 56
whoa all right so I don't want to go all
the way to 56 but I also don't want to
be completely you know the other way so
let's try a more reasonable padding of
16 pixels I think 16 is is way more
reasonable all right wonderful
I like 16 I think that looks looks
really good
and some of the items now are actually
displaying on one line instead of two
some of them are just too big we're not
going to
be able to fit them all on one line and
that's okay all right I like that I like
that all right so let's just figure out
where this value is coming in at so it
was that 50 something so let's check out
this drawer new chair this drawer
component we may need to go to the
drawer item the leg drawer item themes
facing padding left maybe it's here
maybe this is where we're getting that
value theme spacing unit times for all
right where are we using this nested
all right so it looks like we're only
using nested on these ones so that
shouldn't be the problem see these are
the submenu items so this is the solicit
item text this is really what we're
dealing with here
well what we wanted to change and expand
this
let's see maybe that's a default
somewhere in material UI
all right so we may just need to add in
something here to override that default
do I want to double check and see where
that's that was at the second section
said for sure
all right so we're here h3
I just got to figure out where exactly
to put this Oh Lin Wang says use react
for Chrome good idea let's check this
out we got reacts yeah
why am I not seeing anything there we
are it's just nested very deeply
this one might be a little bit more
difficult to give get access to so
anyway I you can see there's definitely
a difference between what we see in our
code so we have this a div that's
containing this and then we have a list
item and then this our list item text
which this is probably where we can try
to put it put our new padding value but
then over here there there's a lot of
other things happening here that get
created by material UI so let's first
try let's just try to put it here and we
can do class name equals put in some
brackets and we'll go classes dot list
item will name it list item and then
that way if we need to add any more
classes we'll put it on there you know
what we don't want this to be all this
item let's call it
are they gonna save parents parent list
item okay that works yeah cuz we it's
just a little bit more clear what we're
we're putting these alright so we want
to do padding-left of 16 pixels let's
save that and check back over here let's
go back to our elements here and see now
we have that padding left well let's do
a refresh to make sure we're not just
getting the same same thing we put into
dev tools nope and it did not work so
let's find out if those Styles even got
applied anywhere and if so where so we
needed them to be applied here it looks
like they did that we had a padding left
of 16 here
all right so if it's still being
overridden so here's what we can do this
is like we are definitely going to be
able to override everything if we do
this style to get rid of this add this
in oops
there we are
alright so what's happened here and
let's let's remove this before we forget
and keep things clean so what we're
doing here is adding in in inline style
which if we know about CSS we know the
inline styles and in that Cascade of
what gets applied they're almost always
applied over everything else the
exception being if we want to use
important with our Styles which we
should use very very sparingly because
it totally breaks the whole cascading
nature of CSS oh I see we have Jeff Jeff
put important in there too yeah it for
sure and important importance like the
next step if this doesn't work then we
go too important but they're like levels
of of how I how I override things so I
don't want to jump there immediately
unless I really need to yeah this one
worked oh but we have issues still
okay
so before when we did 16 here it worked
so I guess we're gonna have to put 16
for these as well
so I wonder now about this the nested
stuff where's that nested class on the
list item all right so it's not actually
on the text part so this nested value
basically what I'm seeing here is that
we can put a padding value here that
won't mess with this padding value so if
we set this to 16 as well it should fix
all of our issues so we can just copy
and paste at this point all right I'm
not gonna try to put it up in our normal
styles because we know those will get
overridden so let's put this here oops
it Save
great alright so that's the look that
that we're really going for wonderful
cool that looks good while we're at this
point let's let's commit this because I
think we're going to move on to
something something different you know
there's one more thing we can do for
this list before we commit I saw I keep
going the wrong way normally I always
have my code to the right of the actual
site in in chrome but for some reason I
left this to the left and now it's
messing me up so we had in our props for
as a drawer now maybe it's at bar I
search open searched
did we bring it all the way up to layout
I think we did right okay I do want to
set all these by default to false so we
had one is true for testing so I want to
set those to false now so you don't have
one of those menu items automatically
open all right so now that we have that
let's commit this this will do a git
status just to verify that we've what
we've changed George where item and
layout that's good what did we changing
drawer okay
the width was what was in drawer all
right it's always good to check just in
case maybe you accidentally hit the
keyboard didn't realize it and change
the component you don't want to change
you don't want to commit that and then
have to undo it and mess up you know you
end up having a couple commits for
something that shouldn't have had a
commit at all all right so we're gonna
do a git add and I'm just gonna put a
little dot there little period and that
means we'll add everything and now this
is something different we're gonna do
yarn CM and that's been set up
who did that did Nicky do that or was
that on though let me know I can't
remember who did that I know I think it
was Nicky's idea anyway we're new to
yarn see them and when I hit enter
you'll see in a second this is gonna
walk a user through or developer through
the steps to make a well formatted
commit message so this is going to make
the commit log be more meaningful and
it'll be a lot easier for someone just
to just quickly you know kind of look
through the commit log and find what
they want so this will say this is a new
feature
most of the things that we do are our
new features and you can enter the scope
this is not mandatory I'm gonna skip it
for now but you could answer you know
what is this effect what we're component
then this is this is not optional we
need to write a short description so in
this case we're going to do narrow the
drawer and
so I'll miss em saying there the drawer
and decrease left padding for drawer
menu alright so something like that it's
just straightforward let somebody know
what happened we don't need a huge
description here if you want to provide
a more in-depth description you can do
that here on the next line but you can
also skip this I usually skip it if I
did something that was really
complicated then maybe I might think
about putting it in here especially I
mean if you're going to do a pull
request you're probably going to
describe it anyway but just you know for
future people that might be maintaining
it if it's potentially confusing then
try to explain it in this case these
changes are pretty minor and
straightforward so probably not needed
are there any breaking changes no not
that I know of does this affect any open
issues I think it does maybe it doesn't
I can't remember if I made an issue let
me look at the issues for this repo so
our current is we have five issues
looking and commit missus formation is
an occupation no it actually isn't so I
guess I never made this an issue it was
just an issue in my mind so it doesn't
affect any open issues now it's gonna
run our Auto formatting linting all our
tests and now it's going to open up
Chrome and make sure things are running
in the page correctly so we don't have
full test coverage right now if we did
the test would take a lot longer but
right now everything's passing which is
great and the final step then is to do
is git commit I'm sorry get push we're
going to say origin and that's
automatically gonna push to our master
branch and there we are now all this is
available at the repo description
the link is in the description if you
want to check that out
alright I'm gonna check the time before
we go on hmm I have no time did I
remember to start that what time is it
yeah that makes sense with the time okay
somehow I just didn't notice the beeping
that was happening okay let me go back
to the live chat I'm gonna take a five
minute break and go through and read
what's in the live chat and answer any
questions that might be there some bias
if there's any live for Android studio I
I don't know if there's I'm assuming
you're asking if there's a live stream
for Android studio I don't know of any
live streams for Android studio if if
any of you know about that please
let us know in the live chat below she
asks to make proper playlists please I
know I know it's it's on my list of
things to do I'm just been I've been
really busy and I've been doing my
trying to do my best to not do a lot of
work at home and to be with my four kids
I'm just really trying to enjoy them
while they're still young and be there
for them I've been working a little bit
extra lately for to get this project
done
I still have clients and then now I have
this JavaScript AF side project going
which I'm not really doing that much
coding it's more like I don't know like
Direction management stuff for that
which between all of it it's just a lot
right now so I really really understand
why you want proper playlists and I
think it's important and I will try to
get that done at at some point
Evan yuan says hello and it says as a
front-end developer in Shanghai China
now it's 1 a.m. Wow well thanks for
staying up and watching so late I really
appreciate that
Brooke says add a max width percentage
to the drawer so it's bigger on larger
screens but only takes a certain portion
of the screen maximum yeah I would yeah
actually that's a good idea
now that I've done it like this I don't
I'm gonna leave it like this for now
when we do check it out and see how it
looks on a large screen if it looks
weird because it's so narrow then we'll
go with the max width percentage but
that probably would have been a better
solution than what I did so sorry I
didn't look over Nikki and and see that
suggestion earlier John Hanson says I
would still like to see an X even if it
sits in the backdrop better you actually
I oh yeah yeah for sure
so John Hanson is is talking about in
the side nav having an X here we can do
an X what we could do like an arrow
pointing this way either one I'll have
to see what is more common maybe I'll
check some other material design style
sites and then that way when you use
your clicks at it also makes this go
here you know that maybe I'll make an
issue for that I don't think I really
want to get into that right now
on the stream because it's it's not a
style thing it's more of a function
thing at this point this stream is going
to be more just style based so maybe
I'll make an issue for that or John if
you want to you can make an issue and
we'll just add that in if someone else
makes an issue for at first a really
helpful thing to do would be to maybe
screenshot a website that has something
like that just to give a visual example
you know especially this
people from all over the world that are
reading you know that are watching and
reading what's in the repo so if English
isn't their first language might not be
that good with it an image I think is
way more helpful to be able to get okay
that's what what is meant here so anyway
I think being able to add an image into
an issue you know whenever possible I
think is a good idea
I don't want to make sure you just
smiling or something though I'm sure
you're all beautiful but I mean like an
image of a website let's see Lin Wang
says what are you doing help somebody to
change UI yeah we're chant we're
developing a website and today I was
just gonna work on the UI part of the
site
Shu mam says create angular apps and
then also added something descriptive
how it's I'm not gonna say well yeah we
just we don't do angular apps right now
we're even no one reacts nothing against
angular I know you know people that are
great developers are using angular but
you know we just on this dream we're
focusing mainly on react so I'd rather
focus on react right now and get really
good at it maybe we use angular someday
I'm not sure but I don't think if we
have other videos we may have angular
videos on the channel I can't remember
offhand though if we have
I can see y'all thought I was gonna use
important huh I didn't have to this time
I controlled myself and I didn't dump
jump straight to using important Lin
Wayne says where can I see your code the
link is in the description to this video
a little take you right to the repo and
you can see to all the code well Jeff
Miller just gave the same answer thank
you Jeff I appreciate it I didn't see
that first oh okay look that's awesome
so Nikki's is Nikki is is rook so if I
you hear me use those words it's the
same person so Nikki says just press
enter on the guests are no questions to
pick the default the default is with the
capital letter so not sure why didn't
pick up on that it seems really obvious
right now after you said that so whoops
wrong way but Lee when we were up here I
actually typed in the N and I probably
did not have to assuming the end was the
capitalized one thanks for letting me
know I'll actually really really
appreciate just being able to hit enter
now all right
one last question before we go back and
do some more coding Nikki says what is
good github issue etiquette asking
because the issue I created on this site
has the worst title effort and I also
don't know if I should close the commits
discussion okay I'm no expert in
etiquette so I'm just going to say what
I prefer
as someone who maintains you know
repositories try to be descriptive but
very brief in your in the title for your
commits so
I mean you may even want to start out
and put like bug : and then say what it
is or if something like that just try to
be as descriptive as you can check out -
if a repository has information on what
they want then definitely follow that
not every post where he does some do but
just in general keep that short and
descriptive and then in your actual
description you can go into more depth
include as much info as you can
screenshots help as well if that applies
and when it comes to closing it
if someone submits a pull request that
fixes it then it should be closed if for
some reason it doesn't get closed when
that happens then if you create an issue
you're probably safe to go and close it
if it's just a discussion if let's say
the discussion comes to a conclusion
where decision is made I'd say you're
probably safe to close that as well yeah
if let's say you ask a question and it's
no longer relevant like you found the
answer you realize your question was
unnecessary if it was answered elsewhere
you can close it that you know that's
going to be kind of a judgement call
type of thing you whether or not you
want to close it I think and if if worse
comes to worse you could always you know
just say hey any objections if I close
this right I'm pretty easygoing when it
comes to my repos at some repos the
maintainer --zz it's hard to tell tone
from just from text but the maintainer
seemed a little bit irritated so
sometimes that happens you know just
kind of realize they probably are
dealing with a ton of issues all the
time so I'm sure it gets frustrating but
anyway that's what that's my advice for
for github issues
I'm sure there's probably a guide out
there that doesn't much better job than
then I just stated explaining all all
that okay let's go back what were you
doing alright so we just finished up
with some things in this side nav now
let's look oh I know what I want to do I
mentioned yesterday that I definitely
want to increase the white space here at
the top of this logo so let's do that
now
yeah I definitely just want to grab do
it for this image or the span that's
containing it I don't want it to extend
any further like to this container
because I I really like how this is
vertically centered here you know what
actually now that I think of it this is
going to increase the height of
everything so maybe it should be on the
the container alright we'll mess around
with it and see which would will be the
best to do if I can do a bit here just
to see so we'll do a padding top I
padding more margin would work here it's
not gonna make a difference and let's
try eight pixels first see this what I
was afraid of is that it would throw off
this so eight I wouldn't go any more
than eight here I don't know what you
all think but eight pixels almost seems
like too much space to me I'm thinking
six I
I like six a lot more let's go with six
usually eights my minimum for that kind
of thing but it just looks way too big
now let's take it off of here and try
putting it on our container padding top
six pixels there we are that looks a lot
nicer in terms of our icon so let's try
to take that six pixels of padding on
the top you know let's let's extend this
as well just to make sure it's not
messing anything else
yeah we have some weirdness going on on
the desktop so we'll get to that next
first let's get this sorted out all
right so this is most likely in the app
bar component so let's check that out
icon all right so the icon and the image
are inside of this div we already have a
class on it this is given the class of
column one I don't think that's what we
want though we want the whole thing
right that's what we that's what we did
so is it toolbar there's a toolbar and
let me just do this
all right so toolbar pretty much does
there's everything so let's add the
class name Oh actually app bar already
has a class as well we could just add to
that yeah let's just add to app bar
since the class already exists it'll
save us a bit of time just go
padding-top oops
need to camelcase that and six pixels
we'll save it and give it a refresh all
right great
so that works we have our padding
awesome I keep an eye on the time
all right looks like we're good we'll be
able to finish out this I'll keep an eye
on the live chat too if there's not a
lot of questions then we can definitely
finish out this Pomodoro cycle if there
are a lot of questions I might end a
little early so I can get the questions
in before my meeting all right great
so we've got it working now I'm sorry
we've got it looking better now on a
small screen now I would like to switch
it to a larger screen and see what we
can do about this is it's not at all
what I would like to see whoops all
right so there's just way too much space
here unnecessary and then it's causing a
lot of unnecessary space here I think
that size of that logo is fine I don't
want to make this huge to somehow like
make up for this I think that would just
cause another problem of having a logo
of too big so let's try to decrease that
space in here so let's figure out where
that space is coming from first oh think
this is it let's check that line height
I mean it could just be regular height I
suppose 72 where is it getting there
all right so let's dig down a bit
okay definitely not from within here to
go up that's odd that's really odd
I mean we can obviously get rid of some
padding that would be fine but the
height is just still just too tall yeah
and our line ID here is just is not
yeah the line nights not really even
affecting that space alright we might
just have to set a height then on this
div so let's try that out
let's go heights and let's just set 30
pixels there we are interesting let's
see what it looks like now
all right let me see I'm gonna go back
to the live chat and see if anyone has
mentioned a better solution okay Nicki
good thought the Nicki says that maybe
it's the search bar that's causing the
height issue I like that idea I did not
even think about that but I I'm pretty
sure that you're right about that so
let's check out the search bar
see
maybe not Nikki I really thought that
that would have been it but I'm not I'm
not seeing extra height therefore the
search
okay if we
all right so if we take away
display:block from these then it
actually but it bumps this up a little
bit and definitely makes that smaller
overall I just want to see if there's if
there are any side effects that are
happening if we do that that we don't
want one thing I notice is that these
are now spaced out a lot farther which
it looks like that could be changed if
we get rid of our or margin okay so
that's that's better I still want to
have a margin over here I guess but it
may be better to actually put that on
the search and it it would be easier
okay hmm
we may be able to Center these
it's gonna work
now let's put it on the do we not have a
ul we just have allies all right
okay guess it's not gonna work
is okay
all right well that's that's I guess a
first step let me go to the live chat
and see what you all think
well John says do you think the
hamburger so this icon here could be
visually bigger the click size is 48 by
48 which is very good the problem is the
UI seems to control that hamburger it's
visual size
yes you're right yeah the the click area
is actually bigger than the size here
yeah I'm open to maybe changing the size
of this I'd go look before I change it
I'd like to check the material design
documentation and see if there's a
standard size that we should use okay
well let's let's go down this hole here
let's go down this path and see what
happens if we try to remove this block
this display block from all these a tags
and and it will go from there so it
looks like the only real issue is the
the spacing and I think we can deal with
that my music ended I'm so used to
having music on when I'm coding that it
just becomes really weird without it so
I'm gonna get something else on here
quickly
all right I have so many messages on my
phone I don't understand
okay so let's get this over to a
component
display:block
all right so in line is now the display
I suppose it's worth it to try to go
through a few of these values first
inline-block actually looks pretty good
so does inline flex and I grid alright
any reason that I should do something
else
so basically ever these inline-block
flex and grid are all looking pretty
good let me know if there's some reason
why I should go with one or the other
I'm just gonna default to inline block
for now alright so let's find these a
tags see if we can put change their
display to inline block so we're
probably here at a power menu item I
believe this is the component that we
want
I'm sorry I meant to say style this this
you link ul link class and this tell
live for the margin you want to take
that away so for now let me just make it
zero because I don't want to completely
remove it in case we need to put it back
in give it a refresh all right not bad
not bad definitely it it messes it does
mess up a little with the positioning of
this search icon so now the search icon
appears to be a little tall we may be
able to solve that simply by making this
icon a little bigger which I think would
be fine so but that'll be the next step
first let's shrink it make sure it fits
okay all right cool looks like
everything fits and let's see we still
have a space here more space than I
really want
oh did it not get applied is that why we
have that space cursor for any kind of
automatic station on that's weird
it should have been there we are I think
I got applied this son yep it was
applied this time display:inline-block
alright so now we've kind of filled that
gap here which is good this could maybe
be a bit tighter here but I think that's
acceptable and let's work on this
this search icon let's make the search
icon a bit bigger and give it some left
margin or padding and maybe and maybe we
can move on and do something with these
search icons and this button here I
think I'd like to change a little bit
about how this looks
let's see all right we're not gonna be
able to do all that I just yeah I won't
have time to do all that but let me know
what you think I don't I don't know that
I really like this button being here I
think it might be better to have just
text but maybe accented in a different
color so we know it's clickable I I
don't know I think it's too much it's
just too much right here I don't think
we need to highlight this that much it
just takes users to access
FUS so it's essentially like a login
button but it's not even for our primary
audience this is for internal audience
it comes my usual time of day to start
yawning all right okay well we're not
gonna have time to work on that anyway
but we just kind of think about what
might work let's shake this up it's our
SVG
all right yeah let's take our SVG man
let's do a oops padding-left
and let's try eight pixels I like it a
pixels looks pretty good let's also see
if we can add if we can increase the
size here so let's go height and I don't
know 25 pixels width 25 pixels and this
is not 35
is it not actually increasing there we
are I said it said too low
alright that gives us a click area of 40
by 40 which is still a little small but
remember this is not going to be visible
on mobile so in terms of just the click
with the mouse this is fine if we wanted
to have something be clickable on a
mobile device on a touchscreen device
you you want it to be like definitely
above 40 I'm sure I think what the
standard is is it 48 by 48 essentially
you want it to be clickable with
somebody's thumb especially if somebody
has a larger thumb so that's why you
want to make sure you have a large click
area you don't want two people to
accidentally click the wrong thing or
something like that but I think this is
okay let's just see I would like it to
be slightly higher so I wonder how we
can accomplish that the best
nice will padding-bottom but you know
what that definitely adds it adds more
than I want to the bottom here yeah
I don't yeah only I want that it adds
too much let's see what else we can do
Hey
there we go we change the heights it
looks like now that's not see that's
just not enough of a change I think
yeah it's we retire like a one pixel
change I need like a 4 pixel change here
I think I'm I'm at a time for this one
so let's let's grab what worked so we
definitely want that padding and we want
it to be a bit bigger so let's just grab
this for now and they can work on the
rest at another time
so in
I guess forget the Atbara menu item no
that's it it would it would be an app
bar right yeah SVG style so I'm gonna
paste that even though I know it's not
you know how it's supposed to work
we'll just convert it a little bit here
save that and oh we already had a thing
with huh interesting
all right let's take this out for now
and just have our padding that was the
most important thing okay one refresh
just to make sure that that worked no
and it did not didn't work
hmm yeah actually it looks like none of
that is being applied hmm all right this
is something you know what this is I
wish I didn't have a meeting all right
I'll have to work on this later on yeah
so normally I would go a little bit
longer and fix this but I have a meeting
so let me check the live chat see if
I've got all the questions and then yeah
we're getting it kind of close to
meeting time so it's a try using flexbox
a line item Center all right okay yeah
that's a good idea for that vertical
line
Thanks up and some condition flexbox can
ignore inline block okay
Oh Saad says what if you outline the
button with the green color yeah that's
a great idea I'll have to try that well
then I'm gonna try very hard to remember
that and try it on that button I I think
that might end up looking really nice
yeah that's that's a really good idea
Oliver says what about tablets Oliver
you're right you know what a tablet
might be big enough to that this would
show up on that's a good point
all right so I should definitely keep
that in mind that we want this to be
clickable even like like touchable even
with someone's thumb good thinking I
love these strings because you all have
these ideas and you know what I just I
don't think about those you know maybe
eventually I might think of one or two
of those things but there's no way I'm
going to think of all the stuff that you
all think of too anyway I really
appreciate all the help
Blake ass has any one worked with react
on Rails if so is it easier or harder
than playing reacts all right so yeah
Blake um you probably know I've never
worked with rails before so I definitely
can't answer that maybe someone else has
has worked
that and and can let Blake know in the
live chat all right so Brooke saying
that pretty sure that space was not
there before the search bar was added so
maybe it did have something to do with a
search bar in any case I think we're
getting we're getting close to a pretty
decent solution here so I think we'll be
alright and we won't even have to really
mess with a search bar too much just
want to kind of get this stuff moved up
a bit and get this the proper size and
click area all right well Matt the end
of the live chat now and it was somewhat
of a shortish a mime a word in an hour
and 14 minutes so I guess it wasn't that
short just went by quickly for me but we
did get some things done we got that
side drawers looking nice I mean that's
as far as I'm concerned that's ready to
launch that looks good and then this app
bar at the top it's getting there it's
getting there it's not this is not
launch ready in my mind but it's close
so anyway it's Friday have a wonderful
weekend I'll see you all back on Monday
Monday the stream is probably gonna be a
little later than normal it's going to
be tough I don't know what time I can
stream because I have an appointment I
have like appointments during my normal
stream time and then after we'll see
I'll try my best to stream on Monday but
Monday and Tuesday I it'll definitely be
different times than normal because of
meetings and things so just a heads up
on that I'll let everyone know on
Twitter and I'll try to schedule as
early as possible so y'all get a heads
up okay Nicki says friendly push
reminder okay cool yeah I will push this
I kind of wanted to get it fixed before
I pushed it but I think I'll just push
it so you have it all I'll do that
though as soon as I end the stream and
yeah so anyway again have a great
weekend I'll be back on Monday hopefully
and it's I was gonna say have a great
weekend again but that would be silly
all right
anyway I'll see y'all later